all right hi everyone welcome to another
uh wolfen language design review part of
our language completeness and
consistency series and we have several
slightly complicated looking topics
today
all right
Expo struct in in terminated evaluation
yep
so
in 13-3 you know terminated evaluation
returns with one argument which is the
reason yep
um we would like to have it actually
return what it could what the
unevaluated thing that it was had got so
far
right
and so you know we so we have it sort of
working although right now it'll only do
this if you have
um
previously uh you know used an extra
struct in the session
um
and uh uh why
well I mean there are several reasons
one of which is that it will add
an extra half second to start to every
kernel startup
to uh
you know since we don't want to be
loading this thing if we've already hit
the recursion limit
um
oh Christ well hang on hang on can I
right so
initializing the data structure uses the
evaluator
um and if we hit recursion limit we
don't want to use the evaluator so we
could we did some work to pair it down
to load it at startup time but it wasn't
zero cost it was I think that's not
going to work so it's not going to work
we're not supposed to start hold on hold
on right
since then I've been thinking it might
be possible to load it without using the
evaluator or to delay the evaluator part
and I could go and investigate that I
I'd be willing to do that if that would
if that's that seems sensible to me I
mean I think we can take a cost if it
takes an extra half second when we are
about to have a terminated evaluation so
what yeah
yeah yeah I mean I presume at these
points we can allocate memory
generally speaking yes
and the the two issues are orthogonal so
yeah
yeah it's fine right I I think it would
be interesting to try to cut out the
evaluator part of this so I'd be happy
to be fine so that's what we're planning
that's what we will plan on is is that
it will so now as I understand it one
feature of this kind of terminated
evaluation it's actually a very
interesting case is that
we've essentially got I mean I hate to
go physics projecty on it but you know
it's kind of a space like slice of what
happened that is there could be you know
we don't in a sense have everything
evaluated but we have a certain time
slice so to speak if that makes sense
the reason I'm bringing that up is that
two things
you know equality testing is is funky
here
right are they the same terminated
evaluation or not
do you understand what I'm asking
sure
right it's about slightly on the state
of the evaluator though that does sit
no
I mean let's look at let's look at the
gallery I mean you know there are it's
you know that that is something I wanted
to discuss uh and you know I'm not sure
how much we're able to affect this but
um
you know so uh
and would you mind boosting the
magnification just a bit I I guess my
screen is kind of small
um so
I'm having a bit of trouble
uh thank you
um
right so you know I think we all we all
sort of can understand uh
uh the first couple of examples so in
the first one we're setting we're we
have a saw we're solving for a and we're
saying a equals solve so we so you know
the solve evaluates the set evaluates
and then it tries to you know evaluate
the returned a and it's like uh
craziness
um
and so we understand that uh yeah yeah
yeah yeah right you know I mean in this
case I mean it's your code is rather
obscure here but I mean what's happening
is that last is extracting the Expo
struct and this is various pieces of
action on the Expo struct which I don't
necessarily understand
right so I do understand what that's
saying it's doing construct but it's
doing it with the defer and that means
that this thing here is going to explode
on contact if I actually run it
uh yeah if you were to copy that and
evaluate it then yes that would explode
on contact
um
by the way should there be any
indication that that's an explode on
contact object
you know and it's print form and so on
no because the whole point of defer is
that it's equivalent to typing that
thing in
okay okay I see and it won't explode and
except for the fact that the a equals
has been
um
evaluated
yes
all right so the second example is
basically the same thing we can skip
that one is kind of boring the third one
is where things sort of start to get
interesting because I'm not sure I
totally understand either the result why
we have both we have two evaluated x's
and One unevaluated X
um
okay so let me comment on this this is
exactly the thing I was yakking about
about space-like surfaces
okay can I explain this sure
okay so think about the evaluation trace
and maybe we could generate a trace
graph here could we generate a trace
graph for a few steps of this I'm not
sure but anyway think about the
evaluation class that the um that you
get from this
there's a question of how far do you go
on each of those experts right
at some point you're gonna you're going
to kind of um
there's other people hearing a crackling
sound
nope
okay
um
uh okay I need to report that for my
setup
um okay so you understand that that you
could go a different depth so let's say
you said x equals list XXXX right
each of those X's could evaluate a
different distance
am I making sense
anybody understand what I'm talking
about
should I do an example
yeah they're nested at different levels
and so obviously they'll evaluate less
the Lesser or the more nested they are
yeah right but you can you can do I mean
I'm not sure how to make the best
example here you can you think about
this as a graph in space-time right
space is the successive elements of a
list for example or other parts of the
data structure am I making sense
with me so far
Yes No Maybe
okay
time is successive iterative evaluation
of something right the thing is
evaluated it's evaluated again it's
evaluated again and so on right
with me so far yes
yes right so there's a front that you
can make of how far you have evaluated
as you go across space right so you go
across these elements each element has
evaluated a certain distance a certain
number of iterations some elements
require other elements to have already
been evaluated in order for them to be
evaluated
right others are space-like separated
they are at different ends of the list
for example and their depth of
evaluation is independent for the depth
of evaluation of the other one
am I making sense
do you understand or not
the point about if you had you know
recursion within a recursion
yeah for example yes do you guys
understand this or do I should I try to
explain this more more I mean is this is
this obvious or is this totally obscure
what I'm talking about
explain a bit more
if you don't mind let me try let me try
and do this okay let me see if I can
find some examples
um
okay hold on
I really should be able to generate this
stuff and and Ian we should be able to
generate it from your
uh um tracecraft stuff but maybe we can
generate so the issue with that is that
Trace graph relies on Trace so if Trace
you know it's okay I understand we're
not going to go to the recursion limit
I'm saying that we need to
we need to just look at this I mean
maybe we can do this with um uh look I
mean
I don't know okay okay hold on let me
just do it as I met a comment that Trace
business is uh the next topic I think or
the third topic on the agenda
okay
all right let's see if I can find
examples here
this may not may not show what I need
unfortunately uh it's beginning to here
um
this is a complicated business Okay so
oh
wait a minute where is this stuff what
was wrong with the tree that you just
passed
um that's not what I was trying to show
what I was trying to show was
see see there's space like
yeah there's trees
okay
yes but this is only a part of the story
okay so so the problem is
I think about this what do I why do I
have a good example of this
um
hold on
uh
I think what you want to say is that
siblings are space-like ancestors
descendants are time like exactly that's
what I'm saying yes yeah
that's what I'm saying so so here
uh
let me do this
oh God
um
okay this is a typical time like
sequence not showing down the page where
a single string is being Rewritten
and it just rewrites rewrites rewrites
that same string okay
things get more complicated
uh
example here
um
yeah okay so this is an example
where the ability to do a particular
operation depends on other operations
having been done
do you understand that you see what I'm
saying in other words something down
here
um
see
the rule only matches after some
previous rule has been applied to
produce that exactly right exactly so
that is a dependency that's a causal
dependency
and sometimes it's just a local cause of
dependency it goes goes down in a
time-like way sometimes there is spatial
entanglement
does that make sense sometimes it
depends on something of a different
place in space
or in our case at a different part
number
people understand no yes maybe
yeah maybe
right so the issue is if you look at
this picture there are different orders
in which you can do these updates okay
each of these pictures shows a different
order of doing the updates
am I making sense yeah right which
update is done when that defines a
foliation of the space of what you know
what is being done when is you know we
have a sequence of of slices here there
are constraints on the slices because
things that are time like separated
cannot happen things that depend on the
output of one thing can't happen before
that thing has been produced
am I making sense sure but I mean yeah
the mounts tube
graph traversals in various ways yeah
that's right that's right it's
equivalence yeah where leaves happen
before their parents
um
well it happened before it's a traversal
order right this thing yeah yeah
so if you change the traversal or the
pre-order post order in order whatever
then you're going to change the way
where you get the terminated evaluation
that's one of the issues I don't
understand about this termination
evaluation because
what you get is dependent on how you
evaluate or Traverse or whatever the
algorithm is that's doing whatever it's
doing
and so if we change some algorithm to to
work in a different way we'll get a
different set of terminated evaluation
in a different order and these
terminated evaluations I'm not sure
exactly sure what the goal of them is
because you get these nested expressions
which contain at some level inside the
expression these terminating evaluation
but surely what you want is just
what what why is it useful to have a
nesting expression with several
terminated evaluations I'm going to tell
you several reasons okay so so first
point is
the terminate evaluation object is a
frozen you know is okay so in this case
here for example in the end we'd
evaluate to this see what I'm saying
in the event the end result is just that
one thing that well I don't know what it
is no in the end that's right we're
sorting a list here so in the end it's
the sorted list here see what I'm saying
but yeah this is actually a pretty good
example I mean we could terminate this
evaluation at a different stage right
and depending on our evaluation order or
our traversal order however you want to
look at it we will get a different
terminated result does that make sense
yeah
okay so this is no dependency like the
fact that one Terminator thing doesn't
influence the result of another
I mean if there's a dependency of the
two then I know I know I know this is
why I'm bringing up these foliations the
whole point is here that that you are
freezing it in at a particular stage
here right
I mean it's um
this is charmingly related to Quantum
measurement stuff too but let's not go
there the the
um okay so now the question is what do
you learn from this terminated thing so
for example
um you know if this thing is confluent
or causal invariant
then it will be the case that you could
always pick it up
and it doesn't matter where you froze it
if you keep going you'll always
eventually get the same answer
I'm making sense okay if that's the case
how often is that the cases are always
thinking
um I think for when you have pure
functions when you don't have side
effects I believe it is the case for our
language
that's not a pure function so right yeah
but I'm just saying how reflected is
that of the language as a whole right
the answer is I believe so for example
for combinators which is what this whole
thing is about right there are all these
different traversal orders here right
and all of them will eventually give you
the same answer so you can actually see
that
show you just for fun
um
uh where is it
let's see here
uh
right so Stephen can I point to a
concrete example in the notebook that
yep
it's one point okay that's one thing
okay so this is Confluence in action
in combinators
okay these are different updates you can
do
is this making sense to people
these are different you know this this
represents a different
uh evaluation front these are different
places where you can do a an update but
in the end
you'll always get the same result
makes sense to people
Lambda calculus isn't it it is yes yes
the property of combinations Lambda
calculus and our language when it is
pure right right and it should be the
case and by the way
I mean okay so in our language just so
we're clear how it usually works well
here these are examples but let's see if
we've got a bigger example okay that's a
nice big example okay of of many
different parts of evaluation now the
thing to understand is our language
always picks one evaluation path
people understand that in other words
when we do our pattern matching Etc et
cetera et cetera we're always picking a
single path
makes sense heads go first left to right
yeah exactly it's blah blah exactly so
this is like this here is basically says
I forget what this is depth first
evaluation okay so this this one here
left most outermost evaluation which is
uh you know we're doing leftmost
innermost I think by default this is
that most outermost that's that that
path is left most outermost this path is
depth first
makes sense
[Music]
so I mean the thing that we are looking
at in the future is being able to
generate these whole multi-way graphs of
all possible orderings but right now but
but so when we freeze we are presumably
freezing
somehow in some rather you know we don't
really know quite how it works we're
freezing across something which is
fundamentally being done with our usual
evaluation order
but we didn't finish our evaluation so
it might matter okay all right now it's
all right point point me to an example
so where it says these don't look so
great near the bottom of
right so here we're mapping
minimize across a table of some initial
values or really functions to minimize
and we two of those things become
terminated evaluations
and uh two of them evaluate fully
and when you look at the Expressions
inside of those terminated evaluations I
mean I guess the problem perhaps the
issue here is that it's really a uh uh
you know well it's recursing more than
we expected not that it's uh a true
infinite
uh recursion but when you get the uh
you know look at those two terminated
evaluations you get these very innocuous
looking
Expressions popping out yep so what
okay well you know on some level it's
you know yeah
because where the heck's the pre-q in
any of this right right that freak you
is something from some internal code yep
couldn't you just set recursion limit
higher if you realized that this was
enough yes you can okay and then that
example is like just below the the the
the screen on the notebook
the thing I find very
hard to understand is if we wrap that
map in quiet to suppress that uh that
message we no longer get a list we get a
single terminated evaluation and
I'm not sure why that is maybe none of
us understand why that is but it's
because the terminated evaluation gets
wrapped at level zero of the evaluator
sequence whatever it happens to be doing
and you it's difficult to to re design
around that
okay can can you explain that a bit more
or or or or
make that more specific to this
particular these two well so you have a
list of operations or of whatevers of
evaluations
and the evaluator before it evaluates
list of all that it evaluates oh right
so in one case I've constructed the list
well but no in one case I have map
oh but your your point uh your point is
that in one case
I first have a list and then map creates
a list with the function applied but not
evaluated and then that list evaluates
whereas in the case of quiet
the you know it's now one level deeper
right that's correct and and it because
it
it doesn't
wrap that terminated evaluation until
Level zero that's why you're getting
that
okay and so guys look there's several
things here first of all there's the
level of canonicalness of the cutoff in
the terminated valuation that's one
thing the second thing is when we cut
off we could be in the middle of a piece
of internal code
what do you mean by level
do you mean okay so look at what's
Happening Here look at what's happening
here okay yeah this is iterative
evaluation this is
re-re-transforming an expression many
times right so I mean level in that
sense I mean time like level so to speak
I don't mean the levels in our trees
see what I'm saying I'm saying maybe I
should call it iteration or something
then you can confuse it with iteration
limit which is actually very related
well yeah I mean it's it should have
been named something like evaluation
limit
because
per se okay look look it is an iteration
if it is not a multi-way system if it's
just ding ding ding ding ding down here
it is sort of I mean it depends on
what's happening in the in the
evaluations but but
I'm really referring to our internal use
of iteration limit different subject
really yeah I understand I understand
but the point what makes this thing
Branch like this is that there is
space-like extent to these Expressions
that allows there to be more than one
place where an update can happen if
these Expressions were all sort of not
space like extended there'd be only one
place you could update and it would just
be a time like sequence
am I making sense
if rather than for example if rather
than Expressions you just had numbers
and functions between numbers yes
right or if you have a single X that's
just going x x x x x x x x x x you know
if you said x equals X
if that was allowed to rap to run around
if say a equals b b equals a I think
you'll get a Pure Line here
you see what I'm saying
doing something I'm saying a equals b b
equals a et cetera et cetera it's got a
b a b a b a b and there's no spatial
extent there's no choice
right so as soon as there's a choice
it is not unique what the next state
will be unless you add in our evaluation
strategy
right given our evaluation strategy
we'll pick a particular place to
evaluate next
not making sense
that's a particular path through here
but the fact that there are multiple
things that can happen at a given level
here is a reflection of the fact that
there is a space-like extent in the case
of this I mean you could also have okay
there's also this notion of Branch like
which is that you've got even in the a b
if you've got a equals B and you've also
got a equals c you have both of those
Transmissions possible then you can have
a branch like separation that is a
choice just because there are two
possibilities rather than it's a choice
because you have to determine in space
which thing you update I see
you you don't need space like separation
to have Branch like separation exactly
exactly
okay so I mean okay the bottom line here
this is a very complicated subject
what are we trying to actually do here
so I hadn't really internalized the fact
that we will be capturing potentially
chopped off internal evaluations with
this extra struct yep
okay and the
notion of canonicalization
with the extra struct okay if we want to
have a restartable evaluation
this is possibly useful for that true
statement or not a true statement if you
want to say we went a certain distance
now go another hundred steps that is
something we should be able to wonder if
that's true because like you change the
Sorting algorithm or something you
change the fact that something caches
some of its results the first time it
goes through it it's not reproducible in
any way you're assuming it takes the
same time to event times time and space
every single time you evaluate something
but that's not the case is it
it's only that that the intermediate
state
is
uh
right so I would say that in some cases
it's potentially restartable like you
know like the the example we skipped
over with those square roots there
there's a typo in the initial condition
which is causing this thing to
infinitely recurse rather than you know
to get to the base case and and evaluate
um and
you know so there okay we have a
snapshot and we could you know sort of
go from there but like in this minimized
example right if you copy that free Q
out and evaluate it right that'll just
evaluate to false which is obviously
something you could never get out of
minimize because so we've sort of
captured a little sub tree but not why
didn't we capture the whole tree I don't
know if Tom white didn't capture the
whole tree
at that stage in other words in other
words take this picture okay we've got
multiple pieces that are evaluating here
I don't understand why we're not
capturing the whole evaluation front
Danny is that something you can show to
any later on I realized I'm not
understanding the question fully well
here's the point I mean capturing the
expression at the point it was caught
not the point it was thrown
I'm sorry the terminated evaluation gets
wrapped at the point it was thrown
you're correct yeah that's what I mean
but and that's why you get free Q you
know which is exactly because it doesn't
have the whole of the dressing it
doesn't have the framework around that
thing it only has
correct it doesn't have all of the
internal Seeker internal code that we
have you see there's like code inside of
yeah but for Pure
top level code it it could do what you
wanted Stephen we'll come closer to what
you want for code that's got you know
sort of how can there be a layer of C
code in between these I don't understand
that because minimize
is implemented in C code and the counter
for evaluation wait a second so let me
understand the counter for evaluation
levels
is the number of levels outside then it
hits internal code
it doesn't count those levels and then
from the internal code it calls the
evaluator again and then it starts its
counter again is that correct does it
restart the counter it's only in rare
cases it restarts the camera no I
understand it doesn't restart the
counter it continues the counter so
there are a few places where it does
restart the counter but not not what are
they oh like parsing something or
something where you really want it to
work like loading a package message
printing
yeah yeah
formatting you know
interacting with the front end so so the
problem I understand the problem is
you
have
I mean in the combinator case I hate to
be maybe that's a very obscure case
you kind of drill down some SSS thing
but around it you know there is context
so for example if we look at a
combinator evaluation
okay so let's let's take here right
this is a piece of combinator being
evaluated right piece being updated
okay but around this thing that thing oh
No actually that's not what that is
um
or is it somewhere here I have some
examples of um
uh
I mean I I have to say by the time we're
using combinators to clarify things
there is an argument that we have felt
fell Fallen deep Into Obscurity but okay
here's what I'm looking at okay
okay so here the colored pieces are the
pieces that are being Rewritten okay but
it isn't obvious
but the the issue is that one of these
might drill one of these might have
evaluate evaluate evaluate and that goes
crazy but it doesn't as we return it we
are not also including this piece here
right makes sense to people
um
right so I mean that's um yeah I
understand that point
and
go ahead
a couple of points which you might
disagree with
um the way we currently do the
termination at the throwing point I
think is very useful particularly with
this data structure in place because it
lets whoever wrote the code know what it
was the evaluator was having trouble
with
um often it is an expression like x
equals X plus one
very very often in a more subtle way
this is uncovered I can't tell you how
many problems in our own code it's
measured in the hundreds low hundreds
but still
um so I think that's important and if
you surround it with too much by doing
it at the catch and uh then you're just
like more likely to hide the the actual
source of the problem the other thing is
for eti's example where we really should
have been able to do it but but the
recursion limit just happened to be set
a bit too low I don't think that's a
very common Pace that we're going to
encounter I haven't seen a lot of it I
haven't seen bug reports about it
um yes it can happen but it's a bit
artificial and once you know what the
problem is and you can usually deduce
that by looking at the result inside the
terminated evaluation you know okay I'll
set recursion limit higher so I think we
want to change what we're doing you guys
guys look look look first question was
is what's inside the terminated
evaluation a full expression that could
be restarted the answer is no
right
now do we know that it's now
in other words can we tag that because
in some cases it's yes
in x equals X Plus 1 the answer is yes
it is a restartable thing
um
wouldn't you need to care about what
would you want internal state
okay so that's a question let's pin that
question okay could we know that it's
not restartable the answer is we could
know because it went through internal
code yeah I've gone through down code we
we could know that
yeah but I mean given uh the caveats
mark raised already do we you know it's
it's it could take a whole different
code path the next time
sure sure we understand all of this we
just want to know the answer the
question is the thing inside the
terminated evaluation a complete
representation okay when we call it
terminated evaluation it suggests that
we have a whole evaluation and we froze
it
okay
yes but in fact
that's not what's always happening
sometimes it went through which I hadn't
really understood it went through
something that is unfreezeable by us
here
okay and what we got left with was just
a fragment
after we went through those layers
right and we could know from the stack
Trace presumably which of those were on
I mean are we returning the stack Trace
at all here
no no
because that would be useful wouldn't it
I mean that that would tell us
that would tell us the path
which led us to this okay because it
would be great except it would be huge
yeah
get into the situation where memory is a
problem yeah okay
it's internal this internal space or
these these intermediary States they can
be exponentially larger than the final
result and how useful is that to Wade
through or even yeah you know I I gotta
tell you it all happens in combinators
that that exact phenomenon happens
regularly in in these things that that
it gets as big as it gets what's that I
don't think it's what we want to do no
no I understand I understand so so in
this case so look a good exercise if we
want to understand this is
uh you know and again it's a very bad
assignment combinations are the way to
make it more transparent but we could
think about what would you do with
combinators how could you return the
partial evaluation Trace so
with combinators what you would do is
you would return
yeah you would return the combinator
expression which you can always do in
this case and the reason but we can't do
that because we're going through
something which is not representable
symbolically by us
right see a combinator evaluator could
quite easily have its state
representable that's that's what you
want that's where you're trying to
capture as well as the bit that went
wrong
there is no there is no independent
combinator evaluator the state of the
combinator evaluation is the combinator
right whereas as Mark is pointing out
there is additional state to our
evaluator which makes it not pure in
that sense
aren't you applying rules of you know
rewrite rules of of the Lambda yeah you
know so those those themselves have a
you know there's there's some sort of
context to it no they're stateless
they're stateless one of them is red one
of them is blue here
but there's a picture there there's
there's a picture
what do you mean I mean that's what the
whole snapshot
okay okay you're saying that you might
need to know the stack traces where did
you apply the red
which you know where in the expression
did you apply the red thing
Forex yeah maybe that's I I don't know
yeah no that's right you're right there
is that issue yes there is that issue so
in other words the current state okay
because of confluence
it doesn't matter what the history was
yeah you don't really care what the
history is but but because of Confluence
which we don't have when the when things
are not pure and when there's a random
or when there's some kind of capturing
or some such other thing
see what I'm saying
right I mean we if if the thing was pure
like combinators then the history never
Matters To The Future
unless you want to freeze in the middle
and have a little look at it where you
are doesn't matter doesn't matter if you
freeze here if you freeze at that stage
right
you can always go on and it doesn't
matter I know you've always gone but you
might want to make a picture of it to
make that picture you need some
knowledge now to make this whole picture
which includes the history you need a
knowledge of the history yes
see what I'm saying to to get the
current state you do not need that so
look I think what we've got here is
we've got
okay what we more have is essentially a
hash code for the thing that on which it
got blocked we do not have something
which is a restartable full expression
in terminated evaluation correct right
so now the question is how good is our
hash code
right in other words to what extent is
it true that if it if we ran the same
computation twice we would get the same
hash code
and to what extent is it true that if
the hash codes are the same it really is
the same
am I making sense
the same means terminated at the same
point
no it means that
were we to be able to continue this
computation okay let's give it the
following example you've got a list of
things okay and they all
you know burnout with terminated
evaluation
okay let's do a specific example because
this is uh I mean it's it's really um
okay so let's say we say let's say you
know J equals J plus one yeah
okay oh God
okay so it says I don't know why
okay let's try this
okay
why did that not give a data structure
you need to evaluate yeah you need to do
like create data structure
at the top there's uh that second input
will initialize things for you
okay
okay so now let's go down here
now the question is whether in that lost
thing if I say same Q
what do I do sorry same Q atat
percent eight
foreign
so it's not obvious that that has to be
true
right right I mean the fact that that's
is because you picked I I hate to be
physics a cosmological rest frame
um
you picked something where essentially
time has run the same amount every place
in space
you see what I'm saying I think a
shorter easier way to say it is it's
because they all choked on the same
expression
no they all will run run to the same
choke point in other words it could be
the case that you have have juice that
you're using up and that juice is you
know after that first one it depends on
the way the list evaluator works you
could have had two plus terminated comma
three plus or whatever
or two plus two or you know
yeah this could have been a terminating
squared
but this this presumably those things
are J plus J plus J plus J plus j a
bunch of times right
why does it say length two here
I bet they're J plus one yeah each one
is J plus one I would expect yeah why
because that's what you assigned to J
but it detected the loop that quickly
why doesn't it generate a um uh you know
uh
um
where it bubbles back to with the catch
I mean if you want to do the if you want
to do this quickly copy out one of those
data structures and look at the
evaluation sub-value of it and it'll
show you
the expression
it is visualization
this should be visualization yep
okay yeah so I don't know why he does
that weird line breaking that's why I
don't use this the sub value very often
but
you can see it's one plus J
shouldn't we have a sub value for
the extra struct data structure which is
just the nominal pretty print of the
thing yeah we should do yeah
unevaluated unevaluated
uh
unevaluated form
or unevaluated expression but hey what
would it be
hold of the expression
why not hold me hold complete yeah
fine
okay our held expression would be our
usual way of saying it yes
held expression of that
fine okay sounds good I'll add it all
right okay so let's come back to this
issue all right so so you guys
understand my point that the fact that
these are equal is not self-evident
it depends on many things about the way
the evaluator works you could put a
random J equals J plus random integer
that might
have different pages sure but but you
don't understand my point my point is
the fact that these all went the same
distance is not obvious
yes yes that's true right and and the
concept of equality
in some sense I mean this is a very
interesting question right because Let
me Give an example with my friend the
combinator again okay there are plenty
of combinator Expressions which are
which which do not terminate
okay these ones here terminate right but
we can also look at a combinator
expression I don't know where I have an
example of one a combinator expression
that doesn't terminate so I think this
one here has has branches that don't
terminate
okay
so
if they don't terminate are they equal
are two non-terminating expressions when
is it the case that two non-terminating
expressions are equal
does equality mean there exists an
evaluation stage at which they are
syntactically equal what does it mean
do you get what I'm saying could mean
they have the same set of possible
futures
yes or it could mean there exists a
future there exists a state where they
happen to be equal which in this
particular case will be equivalent
but
but it isn't
you know and and this quickly segues
into trans-finite numbers and all kinds
of issues with those
um in fact I suspect that there is that
there are equivalence theorems you can
get that go up to you know in the
transplant number case go up to Epsilon
zero so what what does that mean for us
the
maybe somebody can figure this out
immediately if you have a list x equals
the list x x equals the list X comma X
you can think of those as defining
you know when you ask
how do you represent those things
let's see if you say x equals X plus one
the value of x in some sense is a
transpondent number Omega
does that make any sense to anybody
yeah
X comma X presumably the next Omega or
whatever we call that
cardinality of the reels
no it's not the cardinality of the reals
it's still it's still a um it's below
yeah you don't get to that until Omega
to the Omega right
you know you need to go even further
than that you can't you don't get to
that in any
Omega I mean what you get I believe well
I'm the tree is some anyway you've got
some other
Omega the um
I'm not sure that the the actually the
value would be
the
Leaf count I think of x equals list x x
right the value of that leaf count is
essentially an exponential that's not
cardinality of the reels two to the
L of zero
no because it's not lf0 it's an ordinal
number that you're getting here because
what's happening is you're in x equals X
plus one you're generating ordinals
you're going you know one two three four
five you're counting up
yeah x equals x comma X list
you effectively encapsulate all possible
Boolean decimals
no you might be right you might be right
you might be right the thing I'm I'm
asking for which is their Leaf count is
a cardinal I'm not certain
anyway the
my guess is that there will be
equivalence theorems that you can get
for example among the ordinals there are
you know cancer normal form works up to
Epsilon zero and then blows itself up
and my guess is the same is true here
that there is no there's no guaranteed
way to know that you can't prove
equivalence of these things even for
very simple cases I knew even if you'd
need to know the entire State and if the
entire state that led up to that is the
same then it's taken the same path every
single thing every single evaluation is
identical and so you'd need that not the
future but the past no no Mark Mark
that's not right that's not right in the
case of these pure evaluations right
where there are no side effects
I believe you only need the current
state that uniquely determines the
future
independent of what path it took to get
there really yes that's the whole point
that's the whole point look at these
pictures look look look look look look
right if you're not allowed to have any
assignments then the current state is
really everything right right in this
case every one of these different
rewrites here is a different possible
thing that you might have done it's a
different evaluation you know it's a
different choice of evaluation so you
could think about that in our case we
happen to evaluate lists sequentially
but we might not we might evaluate them
in a random order okay and every
different Arrow here is a different
choice of what elements of the list to
evaluate next
evaluation was one of those four
the whole point is for any one of those
four
you keep going and when you and and you
end up always at the same place that's
what this Confluence property means okay
and that's what Lambda calculus has that
property pure Lambda calculus
combinators our Pure language has that
property
now every time as you correctly observe
every time you get something from the
randomness pool or a different cache
from the outside your toast
right and then no you no longer have you
have an assignment
uh yes if you have a different
assignment you're also toast you're
getting it's something outside the
purity of the system it's a side effect
it's yeah right
so okay
so I mean
I think what we're learning here is it
is that best to Hash code right
and it is a hash code that doesn't even
it's a hash code
that is both a hash code for the
expression that was being generated and
for the
essentially evaluation history that got
you there
right because these happen to be equal
in this case but we can't be sure of
that
so two things which
in truth are equal that is let's say
they terminate after a million steps
okay so let me show you an example here
um
for they are but but um there are there
are combinator expressions
crazy crazy combinator Expressions that
yeah look these ones yes yes yes here we
go yes this is actually a good example
okay so this is a combination expression
this is the size of the combination
expression as a functional number of
evaluation steps with some evaluation
strategies it terminates and Summit does
not
okay when it terminates it's always the
same
but it might not terminate
and
so there's no way
you know if we get one of these
non-terminated 7 000 elements
Expressions right
and that's our termination here
is it equal to this thing that used a
different evaluation strategy that
terminated here if we took that
expression with seven thousand elements
and we used a better evaluation strategy
going forward it would terminate in the
size whatever it is size eight thing
does that make sense
but there is no way on Earth we're going
to be able to figure out that this
terminated eight element thing is in any
way equal to this growing without bound
one or this other one growing in a
different way without bound
that makes sense
yeah yeah boy I mean it
um uh
um
I I will have to say you know I
maybe with some theorems and some cases
you might be able to to make right right
I mean look I I I'm sorry I I I see I'm
impatient here but I have a tremendous
Advantage because I've been thinking
about these term writing things for ages
and um you know this stuff is pretty
complicated but I think you know the net
for us is
unfortunately the second argument of
terminate evaluation is not as useful as
I thought it was going to be
I think I disagree with that I think I
agree the Practical point of view it's
very good for debugging
okay but but is it because it is it's
like them having
you think Trace rather needs to get
debugger and that's why I never use it
because it's just it just grows too
enormous and and really this this
expression doesn't grow enormous that's
the nice thing about it well I mean I
think the the fact that we have fact
that we encountered a terminated
evaluation has been very useful in
uncovering bugs and fixing them
yeah but but Mark right now the way we
debug these is
um usually they come to me and I set a
break point in the 2D function and when
I get there I you know
it look at the stack trace and find out
where the function has been you know
where the evaluation has spent its time
huh because you're debugging in a
debugger that's my excuse of course but
having this data
like the free queue what was the free
queue what did that yeah
that's an anomalous case where we just
didn't have recursion limit set far
enough so it stopped it got cut off in a
case where it would have finished okay I
think that should be a an example in the
documentation I think that's a great
example
because I was going to make a suggestion
about this before you added the data
structure with the second argument and
that is that
why don't we have terminated evaluation
work like interterminal where it has up
code and these things subsume each other
and you just get the top level thing
it's just a terminated evaluation
because then you can't really use it to
debug it's like it's like a referee of a
paper saying uh there's an error in in
your theorem
you know it's like it doesn't tell you
what to look for
failed rather than being something that
grows with the size of the expression
well I mean what I don't understand is
two plus terminated evaluation comma and
you get this bunch of these terminated
evaluations that grow with the size of
things well do they how big do they grow
is there a problem well the terminated
evaluations themselves don't grow right
but they mean no but the sides of the
expression that contains them you might
have many okay that's a different thing
we're not worrying about that for right
now we're just saying these are the
leaves this thing it's a Hydra it's no
it's a recursive Hydra that's generating
heads upon heads and so on yeah and what
you're doing is you're cutting off you
know at some level you chop the thing
off and the tree no longer grows and
you're saying the tree might already be
quite big even before you allow even
before you chop off its heads yeah
let's not worry about that for a second
okay if I can if I may contribute uh
right originally we had the design where
we didn't have terminated evaluation it
was just a system exception that you had
to manually catch if you wanted and
Stephen complained that you know that
way you have right if part of your
calculations exceeded like in the the
pure map case then you know you've lost
that result so this way we're sort of
but this is the correct way to do it
this is the right way to do it this is
the thing where as you drill in sort of
a time-like direction certain places in
space you know have they run away okay
in certain places in space you know sort
of time is running too quickly it runs
away and you chop it off and other
places it doesn't but so I've got a
proposal yeah okay here's my proposal
first point is that the print form of
this be whatever that held expression
thing is okay be a short of that held
expression
okay point one that we change the print
form of terminated evaluation so that
that thing is the shorter the held
expression with one exception if it went
through internal code before it got here
and we can detect that assume we can
detect that
then I claim we should display it
differently in other words if this was a
genuine
you know uh sort of a front of the
evaluation we display it by showing
where it got to and some ghosted out
fashion if it was not the front if it
was only part of the front we display it
differently like we display it what's
that can we determine that I'm asking
the
Usual Suspects
yes can we determine that Tom can we
determine that I mean we could we could
know if it passed through down code
that's what I'm asking that's what we're
asking I think that's but that might
be might not spoil
okay if if it's like trivially always
possible through down code it's not
going to be useful well that's yeah I
mean it needs some investigation okay
fine let's assume you can do that let's
assume that the N minimized case can be
detected
okay that what because any time that
it's not going through down code you
will have sort of the complete
expression as it is contained in that
extra structure Jake was J plus one is
going through the down code for set
well and you do right and right the set
disappears right the the set evaluates
successfully and then it's just the the
so I I think that's yeah right it's when
when okay does the thing get left as
context or not is the question and so
let's assume we can determine that okay
that my proposal would be that we have a
nice print form for terminate evaluation
that is essentially a ghosted out
expression that looks like it it you
know we have to some I can I I can
iconic version of this thing was sort of
halted in its tracks and could go
further for the other case where it's
just a sub piece
we have something where there's sort of
a big ocean that is around it and we
just see that in sort of a peephole so
to speak
did you do you get what I'm saying
uh I get I'm not sure I like it but
um
[Music]
well that's my proposal so I mean that
that essentially what we're doing here
is we're generating a print form which
is useful to look at you could if you
wanted to actually extract the
expression from it
but you know on the grounds that this is
useful for debugging but not
particularly useful for further
computation
you see what I'm saying
I'm really not convinced that this
distinction is easy to make in the code
okay okay I don't know I don't know so
let's determine that that's a that's a
separate issue we can come back to that
another time if we cannot make that
distinction then we have a further
problem but let's find out if we can
make that distinction first
even if we can't then we we have
something which is primarily a printful
because the first thing I'm going to
want to know is what is that data
structure what's in there
do you see what I'm saying so why not
just show me
yeah that's fair point
right so I mean show me a short of it
and that'll be you know that's that's
that's the right thing
all right a fascinating topic
um
[Music]
but uh I think we we need to unless this
is Trivial I think we need yeah I I
think we should skip this the third one
might be faster I think that's just
Australia
and that's not important that's the
least time sensitive one so okay all
right okay I I think we've got a
possible plan here let's determine
whether it's realistic right okay okay
bye